Morgan Stanley says SMP could drop 26
percent in months strategists are
warning the US equities are becoming too
expensive which could cause the S P 500
to slide by as much as 26 percent
in the first half of 2023 this is not
the Year this is first half so June 23rd
June 30th recent data suggests that the
U.S economy might avoid a recession
however it has also taken the
possibility of a Federal Reserve uh
pivot off the table making it less
optimistic for stocks the sharp rally
this year has made stocks the most
expensive since 2007 according to the
equity risk premium metric which has
entered the debt Zone Morgan Stanley's
Michael Wilson said that the risk reward
ratio for equities now is very poor the
FED is still far from ending its
monetary tightening interest rates are
higher across the curve and earnings
expectations are still too high by 10 to
20 percent Tom what are your thoughts on
the story well I think what you're
seeing here is I'll translate this into
plain English Morgan Stanley doesn't
think that the economy is getting better
and it's going to be represented by a
market drop in plain English you could
take a look at what happened just a day
ago the market everybody see about it
Diego Market dropped six seven hundred
points like in one afternoon it was
triggered by Home Depot because Home
Depot talks to home renovations also
there's a large percent of Home Depot
earnings that come from when you buy a
home you get rugs Windows drapes paints
and you do a lot of stuff new lawnmower
all these things and Home Depot came out
and said yeah fourth quarter wasn't that
good and we don't think 23s can be very
good at that moment is when the market
dropped because they were really scared
about what's happened in retail Morgan
Stanley is looking at it and saying hey
you know what this thing could this this
thing is fragile how fragile
Home Depot makes an announcement by noon
and by the afternoon you've lost six
seven hundred points so what Morgan
Stanley is saying is that the economy is
more fragile and they think there could
be a real drop and we just saw it live
uh Walmart came out that afternoon too
with some kind of bad news and there it
is live for you it's a very fragile
economy it's what they're saying and
they see it could drop 26 Adam what do
you think
uh so this is Morgan Stanley right I'm
going to use the uh by the way hi
everybody great to see everybody
everyone we want a great looking
audience we have here holy moly yeah
let's just give some credit to the
audience looking our audience looks way
better than I thought uh even you Trump
supporters out there look way better
than I thought oh
uh I think in the immortal words of Big
Lebowski uh Morgan Stanley that's like
just your opinion man so it's we've seek
we see whether it's Goldman Sachs or
Morgan Stanley or the big Banks the
wirehouses or Credit Suisse or UBS
everyone has an opinion if if there's
anything I've learned about the economy
and the financial markets nobody has a
effing clue what's going to happen I
remember when when covet happened and
um what was that March of 20 right and
the economy tanked and I'm in a group
chat with all my buddies and one works
for Goldman Sachs and he we're all like
dude like what what do you think he's
like well I actually sold all my
equities uh a month prior and we're all
like what the [__] tell us dude what
happened and what happened six months
after that the economy the market
bounced back tremendously so I think
what we what we've seen as far as the by
the way how many people invest in the
stock market here show of hands so like
the majority of the room who was like no
way I don't mess with equities I'm all
real estate commodities
all right so a couple Biden voters out
there like a couple but
um what we've consistently seen is
anytime there's a bear Market which we
just saw covet exactly a bull market
follows right up after that time after
time after time so at the end of the day
you have to figure out what your age and
your asset allocation is so the majority
of this room good-looking people looks
like in their 30s 40s 50s maybe anybody
retiring or like trying to pull out
their 401K money anytime soon I doubt it
so maybe you got to talk to your mom
shout out to Vinnie's Mom right there
watch your 401k Mama but if you're not
pulling out of the market if you're not
selling if just like if your home equity
goes down 20 stock market goes down 20
if you're not selling it's called
realized gains uh I wouldn't necessarily
be a concern maybe you have an asset
allocation strategy to be a little bit
more conservative but this is not a
major worry for me so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign